me and him i almost got taken in a lan
lease scam in new york oh yeah yeah yeah
so now here's the deal i saw this condo
in manhattan for 215
000 i love new york i'm like i'd like to
own a condo in new york
and and it would go up in value and i'm
like how bad is new york con i'm like
215 000
from midtown manhattan what the [ __ ]
going on over there i knew there was an
exodus but
christ right how bad could it be what
are you just getting
stabbed on the way into the building 215
000
benjamin explain to them i almost got
taken and by the way
if you look at me i am the guy they hope
buys this because when i walk into an
office this is the pitch that they make
to me
this land lease scam that ben
understands
even a little better than i do so it was
a first of all very important it was
has to be cash only all up front cash
only because banks
and this is a red flag will not finance
this type of transaction
now me i'm an idiot so i see that and i
go [ __ ] cash only
they want the big rollers i'm in
like they're like they want a certain
type of p i think i even said to him i'm
like
i think they want a certain type of
people i'm already putting my foot in
the door to get robbed do you see what
an idiot i am
do you see what an idiot i am because
i'm a salesman and salesman are easily
sold
if you were a salesman out there you're
easily sold yeah it's true
so the land lease is essentially the the
building does not own the land that it
sits on so you can never
technically own the apartment it can go
up at in price at any point
the the homeowner's dues which are
monthly can double
triple quadruple it doesn't matter and
it gets reassessed every five to ten
years yeah so interestingly enough in
the 60s and 70s trump plaza
made a deal with the land that the
building was on to only pay 1.9 million
for the land for over the course of 40
years and we're in the 70s yeah in the
70s wow
when that expired they owed 190 million
to own the
land because land costs in manhattan
always go up new york land costs go up
so they raised the money everyone in the
building everyone in the building all
the criminals living in trump
plaza raised the money because otherwise
you could lose the unit completely yeah
completely because all the land gets
forfeited back to
whoever owns it and you're [ __ ] but
the people in trump plaza
were able to raise 109 million 190
190 million dollars so that they were
square correct well we're not going to
be doing that over at the [ __ ]
what was this place called carnegie uh
carnegie house yeah yeah
and they they have all these and it's on
billionaires roads on 57th street
billionaires row
and i'm an idiot because i'm like i'm
telling ben i'm like you see
uh i said a lot of people are just not
on zillow trying to get these deals but
i'm on it because i'm smart
that's the great article right there
which one is it right there the 99 oh
thousand dollar one bedrooms on
billionaires row yeah this was it carter
hundred thousand dollar studios and
billionaires real highly desirable
apartments that people are racing to
unload
why and then they explain to you yeah in
the case of carnegie
house it turns out it's straight forward
it's a land lease building meaning the
building doesn't own the ground beneath
its foundation
the arrangement is fairly rare there are
only 100 land lease buildings in the
city and means
that the building's owners have to pay
rent to the developers which in a co-op
building of course means that the
shareholding residents
who pay ground rent in addition to their
typical monthly maintenance fees
real estate tax and any operational cost
so if the ground lease expires and is
renewed at a much higher rate
the monthlies can double or triple land
leases can reset as often as every 5
10 15 years as the building and the
property underneath is reappraised when
they do
so this is what is
uh i almost got robbed because i'm an
idiot now they would have explained this
to me but i'm such a [ __ ]
that i was actually looking at this is
like a good investment
and i'm the type of guy that they dream
of because when i walk in
to the real estate thing and i go listen
i found a good deal i know how this
works
i pay attention i got my ear to the
ground 2 15
you know i'll go in there maybe we'd do
a cash deal you know
who knows like they look at me and they
go um
right they go okay so you know it's a
lan lease and that means that you know
like maybe whatever
in a couple of years they reset the
month these they can go up but anything
can go up right
they go hey 15 years 20 years who cares
right they go this guy get him another
steak
get him another steak you want a light
light up his cigarette get a mistake he
doesn't care about what happens in 20
years
you don't care what happens in five
years it doesn't matter you're happy
in the moment buy it you're a big dog
you're living on billionaires row
lie about how much it costs i mean
there's so many ways to try to sucker
me into that deal thank god ben was here
and smart and able to see i just said
white power didn't even mean to i just
went like this i was trying to make a
point
but this is white power now this is a
screenshot there yeah they will
screenshot that and they'll say i was
trying to do white power
all my enemies of which there's like two
enemies i have that write about me
that make like eight thousand dollars a
year to write about my podcast
every day it's like great the true the
true threat to america
the tim dillon show
the alt-right podcast that
has never ever talked about anything
remotely all right
um it's amazing but again it must be so
comforting to just live in a reality
that bears no resemblance to the one on
this planet
and that's what many people have been
doing and they've made louis gomez a
political figure
they've made lewis gomez into like a
divisive
uh political agitator and hey man
whatever works whatever makes you that
85
9 000 a year that you earn
writing about comedy as if it's the most
important thing when we all know that
it's
pretty unimportant um